Very heavily muscled Oliver Mccoll 29
years old,
as indeed is the reigning champion
Lennox Lewis from Great Britain.
It's been said that Lennox Lewis really
hasn't achieved the sort of popularity
in this country that he would have
wished for,
but certainly there's no lack of support
here for him tonight.
Here in the Wembley arena.
Lennox Lewis,
Lennox,
courteous,
Louis,
born and West Ham on the second of
September 19,
65.
Comes in for the fourth defense of his
WBC heavyweight title,
the defending champion as home
advantage.
He's got a height and reach advantage
and is unbeaten,
whereas the challenger has got five to
feats on his record.
The referee officially appointed by the
WBC is from Mexico,
Jose Guadalupe Garcia,
first of what's shed for 12 rounds of
world heavyweight championship boxing,
the WBC title,
the man told her that to Lennox Lewis
champion making us both defense of the
title one and perhaps some controversial
circumstances,
but he's defended successfully three
times and Oliver,
the atomic boma,
it was in the black trunks with the gold
trimmed on the side as expected to be a
very worthy challenger.
Lewis coming in at exactly 17 stones and
the goal 16 and a half stones,
and just about a quarter of upon Lewis.
I'm three inches taller,
has that considerable range advantage,
but Macole has been in with a lot of
very good opponents,
including Tony Tucker,
the man against whom Lewis made his very
first offense in Las Vegas in May of
1995.
Great
last time.
Lewis was in this ring most of the feet
and Gary Mason for the,
uh,
British and European heavyweight titles.
Now Mason summit,
ringside making us come back and
wondering will he ever get to fight at
this level again,
are willing dad ever get the fight?
Lennox Lewis champion Lewis,
and he really needs a big one.
He's not still terribly highly rated by
pundits across the pond in the United
States of America,
whereas all of them are called,
certainly is rated as number one
challenge by the three major governing
bodies of world boxing,
WBC,
the WBA on the IVF.
The man who was the former spawning
partner for Mike Tyson,
all of them are caught in this country,
is expected to give limits.
There's a very hard fight and if he rips
in anymore,
right hands like that to the body of
Louis,
then those predictions will be
completely correct.
Louis tends to start a very tentative.
They did just that in is that last title
defense against Phil Jackson and
Atlantic City and May of this year
before getting to grips with the
challenge than on winning the fight in
the eighth round.
It does throw a very good right hand,
Oliver mcfall and Louis will have to
watch that.
It tends to drop was left occasionally.
Let's try to work behind the Jab.
Let's rather wild by mccall perhaps
wishes to pressurize the champion to get
the fight over with us already as
possible.
I've called very heavily muscled,
very strong,
and reckons he's in the best condition
of his life.
Good right.
Have a good slicing right by the
champion and that's the first time we've
seen about a strong punch by Louis,
but while opening first run the old
arena is by no means packed to capacity.
There's a tremendous amount.
What makes this a little bit of work
being done just underneath his left eye.
Final instruction.
Then to Lennox Lewis,
an interesting first one with both men
letting a little bit go from the armory,
but this pending
one suspects and Louis looking again
behind that has got very fast hands for
a big man
ethic Louis unbeaten.
Remember,
after
25 fights,
always got him walk into her right hand.
I'm not.
Where's the sucker punch that they
worried about?
A little staggers on the referee has
decided it's all over.
My goodness brought an upset on Lennox
Lewis.
His career must be in tatters.
Oliver,
the atomic bomb,
mccall,
the 29 year old from Chicago,
has stopped.
Lennox Lewis,
the WBC and heavyweight champion of the
world,
and the second rod mccall says,
I told you so.
I told you so reminiscent of Mohammed
Ali three decades ago.
Oliver them a call and his own terrorize
can not simply believe it themselves.
It was a right hand delivered with
startling porosity and startling speed
and Lennox.
Drop the lamp almost imperceptibly
unwoke straight onto the classic sucker
punched and look at the difference in
the two corners.
Willis cannot believe it.
His hope perhaps of a unification title
with Michael,
a rematch with Riddick Bowe who knows
Mike Tyson and expected to come out of
on a fight in the offing,
simply cannot believe it because at the
moment that would all seem to be
completely gone.
Pandemonium,
hair and the Wembley arena.
A Lennox Lewis content arts with only
less than a minute of the second ron
gone the fraud can believe it.
It was a tremendous punch.
They hug and lists is smiling well as
lip as very badly cut.
The Not really was that bears testimony
to what was correcting shop on the
father of six children.
The 29 year old from Chicago has done
what nobody has ever done before on a
stump Lennox Lewis and what time did
this most of career is defined by his
two losses.
Then by his 34 winds,
only 17.
Chad's corralled by Louis Bipap,
Po box numbers.
That's fewer than Lennox would want to
grow to be at his optimum,
frankly,
isn't drawn that many punches.
He's been under 40 punches.
Heavyweight averages around 40 in most
of his best efforts.
Lennox is much busier than that.
Sometimes 60 bunches around once or
twice and he comes up with that right
hand better.
Be careful.
While Lewis hasn't been busy,
he has been accurate,
more accurate than rock mine,
but that presents the classic quandary
for the better.
Or is the one who lands on a higher
rate,
better come on blinked that way.
He's having trouble and Louis goes to
the body with the left top trying to get
rock to bring his hands to give them
another shot.
At that swelling left up fighting for
the heavyweight championship of the
world.
If you've got the so far,
yeah,
you to go.
That's right.
Don't make any looks.
Don't touch your face.
Keep fighting.
So far,
Rachman has done a pretty good job of
staying off the ropes and toward the
center of the ring is disastrous moments
for against Moscow and to have occurred
when he had his back to the real that
momentarily Louis Louis smiling at him
as a result,
that's what you gotta do.
You fighting for the title titles.
Don't take it.
Excellent.
Jumping right hand,
Louis stopped jabbing.
He can walk into some right hand does
what's happening now.
You're gonna walk into them to walk to
the man,
use your left Joe Louis with the jab
right to the left up upstairs
combination.
Now he just buyers the right hand like a
big kit man,
Jack Cases Louis across the United
States and the way he fought the fight
you can see as taking him seriously
because he's fighting and thinking was
shades of Tokyo,
Tokyo 10,
nine slash 1992.
This bike Lewis clearly preoccupied with
other things in his life focusing on the
national anthem.
Again,
one of the biggest upsets in history.